the minister rightly recognizes the toll
Stella crazy has been a vocal advocate
for women's rights including campaigning
to make misogyny a hate crime and
maternity rights but she says the
backlash she receives for those views
has escalated after an unknown man filed
a complaint to Social Services accusing
Miss Crazy of harboring extreme views
that he said could pose a risk to her
own children I was outraged that
somebody's response to disagreeing with
me was to suggest that my children would
be at risk and social or should be
removed from me
um you know we can all have robust
conversations debates discussions I can
passionately disagree with people but
threatening to take away their children
because you don't agree with somebody is
not free speech it's a form of
harassment even though there was no
evidence to back up the claim Waltham
Forest Council says it had a duty to
look into the case while leicestershire
police told us it carried out a full
investigation
the police were very clear to me that
there was no basis to the complaint
other than his concerns about my view it
was purely based on his assessment but
the idea that you use a third-party
organization to Harris somebody in the
public eye I think is very very
troubling and she says police told her
she should expect to be challenged in
this way because she's a public figure
the police response I think reflects why
the concerns about misogyny are not just
about the metropolitan police the police
officer told me that my views were
extreme and said this man had a
perfectly protected right and was
entitled to do it in but also then said
that he wasn't motivated by hatred of
women if this isn't hating women I don't
know what it is now this complaint
actually remains on file yes doesn't it
um tell me about that
so one of the very practical things is
it now means that my children have a
Social Services record a couple of weeks
ago I had to take my son to a e and in
the middle of it they asked me as they
rightly do is your child known to Social
Services what on Earth am I supposed to
say about that
but Social Work experts say cases
brought to them even those found
baseless should remain on file you must
establish an understanding of a child's
life story now of course some of those
complaints as we've sadly seen in this
situation may be vexations are malicious
but some of those complaints are local
Authority May initially believe our
vexation is in dismissed and malicious
and have no further evidence to support
them could eventually turn up to have a
basis Miss Crazy says this was
harassment without consequences she
wants to see those who make malicious
claims given a caution or even
prosecuted for wasting police time Nick
Martin Sky News